talking of famous faces of meeting
famous faces there's a weird thing going
on at the moment
picnic about so many weird things
because of Donald Trump but we're
something hearing about all these famous
people that he asked out and you are one
of them lady I change the course of
history we were doing primary colors ooh
which was a film about the about the
Clintons and about that that it was at
Universe it was 97 a long time ago
so actually one only associated senior
Trump with tasteless architecture at
that point and well it still abound the
sense of narcissistic kind of madness
but I was in my little trailer which is
a normal trailer and it had a phone like
a proper phone with a you know land land
like its trailer though so it's kind of
and I'd no one had ever run me on it nor
had I ever used it in fact I assumed it
was not a working machine and it rang
one day and I picked it up and it was
Donald Trump don't hi it's Donald Trump
here and I thought someone was having a
laugh
[ __ ] off no I'm ringing to ask you if
you would like to you know come and
stain one of my lovely apartments and
maybe we could have dinner and and I
just didn't know what to say I was just
absolutely astounded because how did you
get my number
I mean a number that I didn't have so I
just said I'd get back to him I'm so
many ways that I wish I had because if I
had gone out with him for dinner I could
have done
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you
[Music]